hey everyone a new podcast with my buddy
Matt Voltron I know you're gonna love it
it's just us driving down to the irvine
improv what do I have to promote to me a
favor check out my blog I'm posting them
bi-weekly at least sometimes three weeks
sometimes for a week it's on my youtube
channel you can find my youtube channel
at just typing Bert Kreischer youtube or
you can just go to Bert Bert Bert calm
and you find my youtube channel through
there you can find all my info through
there you haven't already rate review
subscribe to the podcast uh and also if
you're gonna do any holiday shopping do
me a favor and if you get a chance or if
you remember go to my click through
amazon banner Lana I did that this cyber
monday we did that we ended up go to
target with and then when we found
something we wanted for the girls we
price check it up against amazon.com and
a lot of times it was like forty dollars
cheaper for like big target items or
like ten dollars cheaper for like
smaller things it kind of blew us away
so we did a lot of our shopping on
amazon com but we did use our bar click
to banner I went to Bert cast and then
click doing them so on my phone so do
that we get some money back so if you
enjoy the podcast that's way to give
back you don't have to though so that's
it i hope you enjoy this podcast like i
said i got a new one coming up next week
with Boston County legend Jimmy tingle
um and I me I'm its multi media month
man spoiler alert spoiler alert your
boys down 17 pounds I'm feeling [ __ ]
fantastic and the vlog coming out next
week you will see all my weight loss in
all its glory as I sing plush by stone
temple pilots in assless chaps that's a
big one I ran into Brody Stevens on the
street with Jimmy tango cool he's in it
Sarah Silverman was on the show map
Voltron Joe DeRosa Josh Adam Myers it's
a great great blog that I'm editing
right now so enjoy the podcast have a
great week
looks like yeah look I know I know I saw
the food came and then you had to go on
stage yeah and then and then I got home
and I was like I was like I'll go home
bed good about skinny yeah and then went
to bed woke up how to shake and then
like three o'clock I felt like dizzy
looking [ __ ] dizzy and realize I've
only had like three out of calories all
day yeah that's my [ __ ] Fitbit until
the end to bring it um so I was like
yeah you gotta eat that's the key to a
diet is [ __ ] eating a lot yeah but
eating healthy and eating a lot exactly
and then you get that I was so hungry I
was like I can't my brain wasn't
thinking straight yeah I was literally
going into the going into the fridge
like are you going should I just cracked
out on this kind of whose car is it it's
a rental car my car get destroyed what
like a couple weeks ago but then I'm
gonna in New York so and I bother about
how did you how to get destroyed hit and
run on the side side of the road
seriously I was asleep did you get
charged for it I got so much money for
it you serious serious nice and you
don't need a car going to New York know
you're gonna Bank that money and wait to
get another card well yeah I'm just so
busy right now I'm gonna put it off yeah
cuz it's just like money so much more
cars it's a it's a [ __ ] it's not
about time to be Carlos no in history we
don't have a winner of a car we have two
cars we don't use one of them yeah it's
like uber is a [ __ ] miracle dude i'm
using uber non [ __ ] styling stores
yeah it's great rental cars and [ __ ]
now what do you call it I take a hoop I
go close someone's podcast I take it
over there I want to do a [ __ ]
parking and my driving i'll be honest
with you I ain't driving i wish i could
get rid of it all together and everyone
who tuned cars this watch this laid-back
guy turn into a [ __ ] [ __ ] the
tester thrive yeah
it is amazing how [ __ ] you ever ever
cut off some one of your friends in
traffic and watch them lose their
[ __ ] mind I do it on purpose no no no
it's just an accident and then they pull
up next to you and they're [ __ ] a
complete lunatic and you're like what
the [ __ ] and then you get closer you're
like oh hey and they're like hey I know
you like sometimes when you're not
around this is what I'm like when no one
sees me I got uh I did that to my dads I
think my dad's partner saw me driving
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] when I was 16
years old yeah and it was like and I was
just like flicking anyone that [ __ ]
questioned me off and right just being
[ __ ] 16 right like instead of waiting
for the light just cutting through the
grass cut in front of people when I was
learning how to drive stick the only way
I could do it is if I slammed on the gas
and filled out like a [ __ ] maniac
they have on the gas it filled out no
just like for some reason it would stall
if I didn't just do it really quick oh
so noxious it was like in a Volkswagen
Golf too so it wasn't like I was in a
Mustang or something what but uh
wait where did you learn to drive in
Maryland yeah no seriously it's like
learn it's not your learning to drive
cuz it's like no traffic and [ __ ] just
chilled out yeah when I got here and
learn to drive all over again oh yeah
the [ __ ] driving in the last night
and day yeah i would say i don't know
this is probably sexist but like my
wife's not cognizant of stuff and I
think it's because she's a female then
cognizant of stuff like being respectful
in when she's parked outside of the road
like yeah there was sparks inside the
road if there's just a spa she'll just
pull into this if there's like say
there's no cars at its driveway driveway
and like three cars can fit so just park
in the middle can I go why are you doing
that pull up to that guy's driveway like
well it's right here anybody haven't now
you've determined how many cars fit here
yeah that's not fair gotta pull out and
I think it's case she's never been
beaten up like she's never been like my
wife also opened a door and if it bangs
into another car and the guy gets
obsessed she's like are you serious it's
just a dick whoa will holy [ __ ] that's
gonna cause a [ __ ] that's gonna allow
[ __ ] traffic jam someone dropped a
wheelbarrow my 134 132 134 want any fun
um yeah like she opened a gay guy did
this one time weird dinner gay couple
moved in move to LA I don't know where
they're from move to LA and that we were
having dinner with them
he was like oh I got into it with this
like meathead today and I was like what
was it he said I opened my door and
accidentally Bing his car like oh yeah
like that would make me irate I'm so
aware that if I park next someone I put
my hand on the outside of the door to
make sure that it doesn't bump into the
car I played my hands image when me in
mind I break a finger before letting
that guy get his car date I fine but
don't you find too if you just say
you're sorry or a perfect someone said
they were sorry to you in it's cool but
you need a sorry oh yeah Oh God pulled
up we were parking to go get Georgia the
other day and it got pulled up and
packed right right up to the part of the
bumper of our car like we were pulled in
and the car was worth like pretty close
behind us and then he pulled it and
backed up right up to the bumper and
also in LeAnn's losing her mind now
we're not gonna be alien [ __ ] out of
here and so I go I just go up to his
door his car window this was Helen
Carson thing I did is I tapped on his
window with my ring so it like it so
it's a nice time yeah and he was and I
was any role he like got scared like but
not scared but just like startled right
and then roll down his window and I was
like hey man we're gonna have a hard
time getting out you mind scooting up an
inch and he was like uh okay yeah he was
like oh you'd see the pain in his eyes
like and he moved up literally a foot
was I what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but people act much differently in
course than they do one foot
very aggressive and very almost
passive-aggressive now check here like
you're playing hockey yeah I'm doing
they'll do it legally it's amazing
everyone like leanna leanna talk [ __ ]
everyone will talk [ __ ] you can't have
to this is my theory on it is your body
doesn't know like your body is [ __ ]
alarmed by all this stuff
winds up but your body isn't moving at
all like all this scary [ __ ] is
happening but then you don't run or
fight you're just sitting in a chair so
if you don't if you don't let it out
verbally you're not letting it out at
all and you just stressed the [ __ ] out
yeah what was it our bodies on me for
this [ __ ] this is all new yeah I always
think that the people with anxiety
disorder were really just [ __ ] trying
to like try to regulate or process all
the information that they really have a
hunter's brain like like I can go out
the wood would hum for my food brain and
then all this information just
overwhelms that sensitive brain there's
all this stress that comes in as a like
in a net that it feels like a danger
like real danger even bills stuff like
that it seems like danger but you can't
you can't fight it on an instinct level
there's too many steps and you like in
the nature you either fight or you run
and if you can't pay the gas bill you're
just like what to do with it that's why
I was go running
usually when I come back I have a new
business idea I can't I can't I haven't
been able to run this week today I tried
to run I couldn't run at all but I think
it's cuz I had low calories I had a
salad and literally soon as I the salad
I sort of feel better yeah maybe I'll
get a milkshake when I get there yeah
really crank it up it's so funny like
all the different diets everybody says
their diet is right there's like the
high-fat no carb diet there's the vegan
diet there's everything like everyone
always step something be like no this is
the real way yeah and whoever's talking
I believe them I go off that guy's right
oh no no no this vegans right yeah I
don't [ __ ] know he just got a [ __ ]
exercise I don't eat like a maniac
buzzer Rogan I said to him I said yeah
I'm dieting he was what kind of diet are
you doing and that's like that's like
putting it really to the fire because
you know he's ready 19 million dietary
books he's friends with all the [ __ ]
guys that train mixed martial artists
and can feed them my kind of ballparked
my diet moans like lean protein lots of
greens lots of fruits no I said I said
lite-on breads and he's like light on
brad's and i was like no breads really i
think breads are really bad for you they
are but i mean they're everywhere it but
they're so good they're great there's so
what at what better way to hold me ya
have it in the guy cabin [ __ ] lunch
doesn't be good at dinner that's what I
said whatever you want for lunch this is
the full charge that I have whatever you
want for lunch I'll work out and then
have a reasonable dinner with no bread
now you're only 20 pounds overweight
dude i'd be happy with 20 pounds
overweight I've been swimming you out
like crazy yeah I realized that I
realized I started paying attention to
the fact that I have high blood pressure
like what's your blood pressure it's uh
it's good now but there was a day where
I was checking it and I was checking it
wrong you got really high like like 170
year older like 110 yes cuz I was uh
because I was panicking about it and
like walking around and not measuring it
correctly so I went to a doctor got my
shoot straight now get some pills
[ __ ] exercise every day and now it's
it's almost perfect but I started losing
weight and I started liking that so I've
been exercising yeah it's I want to make
a scale that like you just explain and
type into it that you're starting a
weight loss program and then once you
step onto the next day you step on it
just says your lighter anyway right that
inspires you yeah cuz I think the key is
just getting inspired this one you it's
funny for a star too because you can
really that's when the pounds go
I lost 12 pounds in six days it's once
you get close to your fighting weight
that's when the pound slow down oh right
now right now I'll use to it right now
I'm stuck at like 243 gown I lost it i
shredded it like the first six days and
then the last few days I've just been
like juggling 243 244 I'd like to get
rid of I'd like to get down to I'd like
to get down in the two 20s and I'd be
like really [ __ ] happy mm-hmm and i'm
still obese but it's like obese enough
for my blood pressure is probably back
to normal it's American fan American
Fame Bailey obese is American yo you
ever be in the Midwest where they're
like oh what are you worried about you
skinny yeah he's skinny I just read
stand up I said one time I think I was
in like Omaha yeah or or des moines and
I said oh I'm so fat and they were like
no you're not I was like no here I'm not
fat but in LA and like everywhere else
I'm really fat on planet earth on planet
earth that you're not fat I think I'm
moving to Nebraska where I'm not fat
well now look at like I said like final
stage 2 50's the threshold of being able
wipe your ass is that right yep 256 foot
that's threshold right there so you got
to employers getting difficult yeah
where you start going to wipe your
assets and you feel like and you're like
your fingertip in it yeah yeah Wow 255
is what I was the heaviest at and I
definitely wiping your ass you've got it
like its pain in the [ __ ] it's not
easy I got up
I'm like 190 right now
I got up to like 210 i did a tour with
josh this summer the summer yeah we were
just hanging out but he's he's like
super healthy right no he likes to eat
then people love to eat really even
they're just naturally thin they love it
little more cautions does work out he
works out but he's dead no matter what
whereas I just blow up its day-to-day I
got beef in one day fat the next it's
like it's almost like instant karma with
what i'm eating or drinking or
exercising with
Howard you guys good I was like yes 20
pounds everything I now I think they got
a scale with the June like in the middle
of my what cuz I never thought I ever
got over 200 I was like 210 how's it get
the [ __ ] out of here we did the we did
the Northeast really colleges I know we
did the like some Cedars
Wow see still doing dashboard oh yeah
that's gold forever I guess I guess went
on like that right I took forever so
he's gonna be idiots on the internet
what do you do what do you guys were
like what do you want out of it what do
you want to sit home you know or you
want to just a job for the restroom [ __ ]
alone on a job and if you can get asses
in the seats for your nighttime job
that's even better oh and the hisses is
not just sign for that yeah it's perfect
wow you know why why why switch it why
switch if it's working yeah
he's always something I wish I hung out
with more because I really like him yeah
but I just my lifestyles not set up to
do that travel for a living and then
when you're not traveling for living
you're traveling for living yeah I
always want to like home and go hey man
I want to go surfing this week tell me
when you're going i'll come over surfing
with ya Oh as soon as you do that are
you waiting for the car behind you to
smack into you kinda to see that but you
know I got the basic coverage on this
car so I'm down for whatever is he still
surf along I don't know I don't think so
rude well I mean he's got the show but I
don't know he's mentioned it uh he's
mentioned that he's still serving job
oh no ma'am
you scare the ocean yeah scary ocean
sometimes I am to hear that white lives
matter joke I made last night yeah yeah
no way did a horse [ __ ] each mad anymore
yeah I should didn't you say before an
like this is a new joke i mighta I don't
do that don't do that I don't know I
said it after and I said it at the end I
said all that joke will never be told
again I got a joke that was getting
groans for a while but I knew it was
good and I finally made it work last
night what was that it's like a
one-liner so that's that's easy to get
it wrong but it's like it's like I go
out with a lot of questionable girls and
welcome over Netflix and chill next day
is nothing but WebMD and panic Netflix
and chill with us do your bidding and he
never worked before I said that
questionable girls thing up front cuz
it's too much of a one-liner yeah you
know
that's also a [ __ ] joke that probably
won't be funny in a year you know these
internet turns come and go oh I know
tell you mean I did a one letter last
night that I hadn't done in a really
long time and well I love when you find
a one-liner that you wrote and you can
you forget you're like oh [ __ ] yeah I
could tell that mm-hmm um I wonder how
often in the early 80s see my brother
and my one letters are way too [ __ ]
wordy I don't do them enough right so
once i get them to kind of work I go ad
it's fine right I'm like you know what I
am I'm like I'm like the house flipper
of comedy okay I get things up and
running and I'm a good salad it's fine
don't want it if we can just pay a
little profit off it we're fine if
you're gonna change kitchen anyway um
you should have a twin brother that does
the details if I had a twin brother who
was meticulous yeah and we could go out
on the road and I just start the
material and he punch lines it just goes
to and goes hey thanks man and then i
might go sure I'm gonna be working on
the new stuff hey I need you to gain
some weight for the new stuff by the way
for it to work you too thin for the
punch line my [ __ ] the joke was a
joke I wonder how many times in the
early eighties a black guy went to cough
and everyone thought he was about to
beat bugs yeah yeah let's get you yeah
like it's laughs I seen it um this
traffic's [ __ ] unbearable ya know
every day
I can't believe I used to do this
patient is twice a week to go out to
Brian everybody to do yeah when I first
started I used to do a lot too and I
used to have a day job so Dom I had a
job in Santa Monica and I just never
bothered move and I lived right here oh
I would got a day job [ __ ] Irvine and
done every [ __ ] move in the move
right but sponsor [ __ ] her mine [ __ ]
her like develop out there and it was
already in like Jeff Keith did or
something hit me grow up and like I
always thought he did he grew up in
irvine and that's how he started his
orange county kids that start north
county which is perfect for funny thing
is when kids start in orange county and
then never bother to come up here at all
I'm not saying move they don't come by
the new spots up here that's bonkers
yeah
but then again I [ __ ] get it because
you're gonna drive all the way up here
just a bomb in front of hipsters I have
a harder time winter feed I have a hard
time justifying do it sets in the city
just cuz I go well it's it then it [ __ ]
with my night yeah like them then what
like what do I I don't go I don't go to
bed on time and I [ __ ] it and I can't
take the girls school in the morning or
I'm wasted for the next day yeah it just
I don't think stand-ups meant for like
married people maybe not it's like Mary
if you're married just gotta leave your
family all together to go do it ya can't
even have the temptation of them being
around I'm not even married but like
when eight o'clock swirling around I
have a spot in the city I'm like oh yeah
I could really stay in Oh Joey Diaz was
like dog I got 11 15 at the store and I
was like why they've been giving me like
1245 1am and I could i only make it half
the time and i'll call and tired alcohol
and drunk i'll call in whatever
because it's just it's just pointless
it's like a dare it's like they're
daring me would it be too much to ask
them to start doing things start to show
at five ha ha ha no because I'll take a
shitty spot at 6 45 I'll take a
six-point now let them still have the
prime time you know but like Sebastian
close it out [ __ ] bill or Joe or
somebody Sebastian bill Joe their
[ __ ] their [ __ ] their owners if
they want they are [ __ ] pave beaters
is at it like they love hitting the
clubs hey do they love being at the
clubs yeah I like being at the clubs
when like everyone's there yeah but like
I want to shoot myself in the [ __ ]
mouth I go to the improv and it's like
most people i've never heard of and i'm
on the show and you know and you're like
oh great so I don't I not only do I not
to get to watch anyone shut sets it's
really fun when you run into people you
know yeah like I went there this
Thanksgiving week I had spots I to spot
the improv it's always better if you
have a spot let's face it oh yeah ah you
have a reason to be there but you
brought calling for spots next week at
the improv and do some spots next week
Colin I've done the hot spots [ __ ]
forever in the city it's fun because
you're only doing like 10-15 minutes so
you have no responsibility you don't
have to close out the show
ah hey killer bomb no one gives a fun
yep
so that's the upside but 1245 at the
store I can leave you feeling dirty yeah
I can leave you feeling like that you
know when you go out there and there's
six people and they won't even look at
you that hurts with yours um I've I
think I've a surgery next week I had on
your wife my head get a cyst removed or
an ingrown hair I was [ __ ] lump on
top of my head I think it's insist I'll
find out whose idea was that you dr.
yours uh my wife's of course she told
you said what is that noise like I don't
know speaking their basic insurance on
this car look what's in front of us Oh
obviously getting paled by [ __ ] metal
that looks like something out of a
horror movie from the two early 2000s
it's guess I straps on it yeah
I wish I could just like just smoke pot
and then that would be my my cool down
at the end of the night yeah I've been
getting into that it's all right but
it's not my favorite buzz in the world
yeah I'll calls my favorite buzz how
Paul's my favorite buzz but alcohol is
very fleeting and now i can't sleep off
alcohol oh that age to wear ruins my
sleep so I'm not crazy about alcohol
anymore yeah it does [ __ ] with my sleep
[ __ ] with my next day like it and I
won't like it it didn't for like up this
whole year I never once noticed the
problem honestly ah but man yes two days
ago no yesterday I drank Thursday
yesterday I was [ __ ] out of it all
[ __ ] day yeah you because you didn't
get any rest that I haven't drank in a
week so I felt really [ __ ] amazing
yeah out of it like yeah disconnected
like just found myself going like like
shaking my head and being like wait i'm
alive i'm here i need to be waking up
right it's funny you ever go to the
doctor and tell him exactly how much you
drink and oh no stop i shook the doctor
goes wow this is great here i can tell
you being honest with me yeah there's
one upside i think your candor so
refreshing i thought i was 5 10 I was
like yo I thought is 58 this whole time
I'm gonna get so much more [ __ ] now
it's funny when the doctor tells you
exactly how you supposed to live your
life though and you like haha i can do
it for like two or three days do you
hear the joke on me on stage last night
be easier for me to seamlessly merged
into a homosexual lifestyle that [ __ ]
changed my eating habits I know it's so
hard I did it for like 3-4 days when I
was really scared about my blood
pressure I'm eating fish I mean oatmeal
I'm working now I lost like serious
pounds
I've been good I've been really good on
this diet but I just had no energy today
like I literally was like and it was
just I just did a shake and I just I'm
putting so much [ __ ] green stuff in
this shake yeah but I'm wondering if
it's gonna [ __ ] me up at one point hang
on a sec Leanne will you grab my Fitbit
off my charger in my man cave
um literally like tons of [ __ ] kale
oh yeah celery kale wide-scale so
popular right now it wasn't popular 10
years ago it was the i don't know i
think it's just high in nutrients and
roughage right so it's good for your
intestines I got some Kelly other day
they'd only take the stem out of it Oh
watchos like I'm seedling a leaf oh yeah
oh it feels like you're [ __ ] eat my
leap all right like I mean to [ __ ] a
maple leaf or some [ __ ]
I mix my k love I only know straight
kale oh I blended up in my in my Vitamix
with blueberries raspberries cherries I
probably love kale my say my shake don't
even taste good anymore I'm so addicted
to kale putting kalin to it yeah I don't
even know if [ __ ] thing tastes good
anymore again sounds like it's working
how much did you pay if you could put
your car on the back of a trailer and
just like almost like a fairy yeah and
they'll say listen we'll take you down
to huntington beach and we'll drop you
off on the you know on the accident
huntington beach we're working this
weekend i would pay maybe my thirty to
forty dollars a day for that oh yeah i
definitely pay i pay fifty dollars to
sit in my car bill the back of a tractor
trailer and just fall asleep just pass
out listen to music not pay attention
you know what's funny is there's a train
that goes to irvine I don't know what I
don't know what the schedule is like
though there's not a trained color is no
there's there's a am track you can look
at that phone but it's just gonna say
what I'm saying no they thought is Jane
Murphy took it down no I gotta see the
angle and sometimes she got buzzed last
night yeah she was hitting it train from
LA to irvine
it's just this picture a bunch of guys
running a train on a girl no you're not
[ __ ] around you know how long the
train takes two hours Oh does it just
like the [ __ ] car ride gu chillin oh
my god dude it leaves every no this
can't be right I take a bus Oh losing a
bus why not most takes a long time the
methyl if it's a bus that makes stops on
the 50 no great 20 be able just kill the
[ __ ] train maybe [ __ ] from this is
Rick I'll tell me I've done it San Diego
and it's a nice ride and it's a seating
cried they start getting close to the
ocean sometimes worst the worst la la is
the only place you can take it from is
the union station station well there's a
train you guys have to downtown anyway
here's to train new you you could take
the Union Station oh the an takes that
all yeah metro no one takes it i take it
it's [ __ ]
you think it is slightly shady slightly
shady characters other it's [ __ ] it's
pretty great
assuming it goes where you want it to go
you know it doesn't go everywhere see
suburban that each I'm gonna pee
to Irvine let's do weekend
80 I can take the [ __ ] 440 get into
545 go see a movie take the two o'clock
get it at three o'clock it's an hour
away yeah so I'm saying and you know you
probably don't want to take the train
back to your house once you get the
Union Station be you in hoover from
there please hit can take it straight
back that's a problem oh well [ __ ]
deaf spend the night get the hotel and
do it that way but you know it's it only
comes back that's the thing nine a.m.
12pm 2pm and 6pm that's why you get a
new word John waiting to get a goddamn
supershuttle the fever over to John what
not bad let's see monday to friday when
did fridays but they got a lot of
[ __ ] rods VA you can't take the train
back to LA until like firefox latest
that's around so if it was in there
otherwise all of the comics will be
doing that [ __ ] oh god be again on trunk
[ __ ]
mind back and forth
going down at Disneyland I should reach
out find out there's an uber driver who
wants to do stand up right and say hey
man I'll give you half the money and the
set yeah Ian a [ __ ] umami burger oh my
god
actually got recognized by an uber
driver last week such a proud new dude
he was doing this [ __ ] I was with Ari
never get recognized I was it Ari and in
New York yeah and we were just taking
around like I was I was going to get a
sweater for the show we were doing the
big j thing yeah and i called me sick
hey Marisa meet so i went over his place
and then we walked around the East
Village the lower east side and the east
village and then literally he walked me
to my hotel and we stopped by rei and I
never get recognized inside I'm not even
[ __ ] I'm not even exaggerating inside
that REI I got recognized 5 times 5
times 5 times watch people rhian by
people who worked at rei what sorry I a
recreational expert and it's a sporting
goods store like okay outdoor [ __ ]
gotcha that's and by people who work
there I got recognized once from doug
loves movies I got recognized ones for
stand up and then like three times for
travel channel
but catcher's mask
mom catchers bath today only get
recognized more give me like a hog you
guys whenever they got the story I don't
oh this just opened up yeah yeah I
looked at the map it does have pockets
words something I can't be that [ __ ]
bad all right this time of year is no
good people out shopping people out
party
sunday is usually the best day for this
but I mean look at this [ __ ] nonsense
everyone's going to goddamn la [ __ ]
yeah it's Christmas party season in the
comedy clowns hello I don't work well in
creating parties Christopher is it tough
someone said to me the other day I want
to say was sooo girl was like he working
all out right now I was like I'm taking
the whole month off he was like oh
because of christmas parties and i was
like no i didn't think about that segura
took it off this year and toshi's to
take it off really oh yeah and it's
smart
because I remember one time I didn't
know any better and I was at brea and I
attacked somebody in the audience it was
in December and they were on the phone
they were on the [ __ ] phone and I
attacked them nowadays I wouldn't even
give a [ __ ] yeah they roll those dark
windows up my fingers blown out and I've
rag Don this woman and the whole place
turned on because they all [ __ ] knew
her he hasn't got a damn office party
yeah
told you to be so much a magical got on
stage and he goes you know Matt selling
CDs if you guys want to take the magic
home with you what I'll do right now I'm
not sure he's always doing something
he's always employed he is the most
working mother [ __ ] in the world he
just as good he's just good he's gonna
be successful in whatever the [ __ ] he
did absolutely he just chose stand-ups
he wanted to do it yeah he would have
done [ __ ] business model did you
think he business model dinner do you
think it's part of his DNA is that I'm
going to succeed I think this part of
his DNA Mexico planning and [ __ ] that
comes with it and there's there's like
full force failure doesn't faze me and
then failure doesn't happen that much
because it doesn't faze me mentality do
they have to do with him getting into
like the [ __ ] business in the
business world first I think it does
like I think he actually liked the job
you had before he started stand-up so he
wanted to make sure you like stand-up
even warm and you know you know be
successful at yeah he's an interesting
guy man like that is I mean he's been
working since the day he rolled into the
business yeah like I remember meeting
him remember everyone told me you got
you think you gotta see how magical to
stand up I saw him enough blown away I
was like [ __ ] man this is like
meticulous yeah like he's God he's just
as destructive yeah and then cuz i was
talking home he was like yeah you suffer
from mitch chappal I was like wait what
the [ __ ] like I never even met Mitch I
never I never I met Mitch one time
passingly not even like hi mrs. Burt
more like hey man big fan like that kind
of [ __ ] thanks man yeah he was in blue
sunglasses like blue lenses and alls
fingernails painted I'm so stupid I
could have gone
you know I was already working the
improv he was out now entire ontario
right before he died it's the last album
they put out do you believe in gosh yeah
and I could just go to god I'll do it he
would have put a hamburger in front of
my face I could have watched me temper
but I'm like now catch him some other
time like a [ __ ] idiot
yeah I wish I'd seen him live I'm acting
I saw him maybe like maybe I saw him
twice maybe I saw him that night at the
improv new stand-up I don't really
remember and maybe I saw him at the
comedy cellar one time I don't remember
but I wish I'd seen him like I wish I'd
known and gone and seen an hour his guy
I really regret it it hurts to think
about yeah same with like I I got to see
Chappelle a lot when he was younger and
like hungry like in like was like not
that he's ever been hungry I don't think
he's got that mentality like yeah right
he's more shows up on it he just does it
22 happens to do and you know but I that
was funny [ __ ] watching him do stand-up
lake by my age I guess yeah I think he's
exactly my age Cody 41 oh that I'm older
than him but he I watched him when I
moved to New York started stand up to 26
he was polite 25 and he was just my man
has already a 10-year vet at that point
he was at a man he was good like that
sounds so silly to say but like he was
so [ __ ]
so casual on stage the I'll saw him get
no fight one time on stage heey made a
joke about black people of cigarette
companies marketing to black people like
the cools and the menthols so ya know
just it's just a it's just a matter of
time until they start making fried
chicken flavored cigarettes watermelon
play with cigarette right then he there
are these four white guys in the road
that loved him loved him they were grown
I mean they were not grownups they were
like probably 27 whatever they loved him
they were [ __ ] so into it I was
working the door and he is back when you
smoke in bars and he asked his that he
was drunk applied pretty high and he
asked one of the guys in the front row
if you bum a cigarette uh-huh and the
guy goes yeah it's fried chicken flavors
uh-huh and Dave forgot he told that joke
and was like what did you just say but
then the best is the guy's response he
goes it's fried chicken flavored like
almost like like if you didn't know that
you would if that he was trying to say
timidly like I didn't mean to say this
like a day but it sounded like he was
going like real slow to an [ __ ] like
it's fried chick Alec like yeah like and
Dave I don't know if they threw a punch
but he like said some of the guys [ __ ]
you man and then the guys and then the
guy was like a grown-up he wasn't gonna
take [ __ ] I mean I'm nothing against a
probably play 115 pounds back down yeah
and so the guy was like a man you go
[ __ ] yourself I wasn't being a dick
right Oh same one of your jokes and the
guy goes and then David J was too drunk
II didn't remember it one of his jokes
it's like I Chappelle show sketch yeah
and then and then literally didn't real
goes wrong they went at it like all the
black comics jumped in and started
[ __ ] trying to fight these guys oh my
knee a little Schaefer had to split
everyone up and and no one everyone
thought these guys with dicks and these
guys got kicked out and I was the only
one that heard the whole thing right and
I couldn't say it to anyone everyone was
like [ __ ] that man everyone's [ __ ]
racist and I was like well actually you
don't want to pick
side I didn't want to massage he but I
was like I was like guys I'm a fan of
everyone right now but this is what
happened but you didn't bother right I
didn't say it worse already picked out
its I'm gonna help me to tell them she
bellies drunk but yeah i miss you i miss
those days in New York when I just I
remember I remember thinking I can't
believe they're people to just go to bed
right now I'm that guy Oh gonna
bestinvest tonight would have been
really great nights just go to bed I'll
do we should cancel the show's calling
lazy to work calling list work oh I
could [ __ ] it sleep tonight I could not
i'll tell you why i could not drink cuz
if i drink it just means tomorrow's
gonna be a tougher day oh yeah yeah it
sounds like such a [ __ ] reason not to
drink you gotta face facts though yeah
you know like you can get you can get on
with it if you do it every night you can
get on with it if you do it every night
every night and um why is that such that
when you do it every night it's not that
bad hangovers are that bad but then when
you do it once in a while hangovers are
[ __ ] atrocious um because your body
produces chemicals to fight the alcohol
and then all these chemicals are left
over in your body so when you start
drinking you're already just evening out
you're like ahead of the game and so
your body is producing all these
chemicals to fight the alcohol and
they're producing it every day look good
at it these fireworks were [ __ ] bomb
going off we're right here up here no
looks like literally like right your
left I just saw fireworks it's not even
close to Disneyland so keep going about
your well you you know in other words
your body gets used to the chemicals
that your body produces is actually what
gives you the hangover and but when
you're constantly neutralizing the
chemicals with alcohol you don't get a
hangover as much you're also used to it
but if you didn't drink for a week and
then you binge drank all those chemicals
that fought the alcohol that your body
released are left that's why they called
hangover it's like leftover these
chemicals that fight are left over and
they make you feel really bad and that's
why if you have a drink when you're
hungover you feel better because it
neutralizes those chemicals [ __ ]
that's why people can't quit heroin
because their body is fighting it and so
they're neutralizing it and then when
you no longer neutralizing it those
chemicals are left over and they make
you sick cuz they're that strong really
yeah she's fighting poison I mean like
this has been kind of like a two-day
hangover yeah there's that too I mean
your body's just like it becomes like a
fluid that your body is used to dealing
with almost like it's almost like a
nutrient anybody's like hey where's the
[ __ ] we're used to yeah we don't
function properly without it
and that's physical addiction oh ok oh
that's a nice way to come about I mean
it you know once you realize that [ __ ]
you know it's not gonna last forever
then [ __ ] it just you know wait it out
bunch of goddamn movie yeah I don't know
Fred job you can also exercise a
hangover clear out of your body really
absolutely film it's just is this your
theory herb this just works for me go
first man go for run you're gonna feel a
lot better yeah cuz again your blood
just like pushing those chemicals
through you know you're just clearing it
out just like if you had a candy bar and
felt like [ __ ] if you went for a run
you'd feel better too I will candy so
buddy I think they're [ __ ] yet to eat me
like ice cream and stuff when you're
dieting again you're all these I always
mix and match all these diets like what
wouldn't there is is there no like good
diet chocolates all right like candy
bars especially if you only eat dark
chocolate opening its dark target when
there's rocky mountain things haha they
got those all gonna get a [ __ ] load
up on chocolate to me it right load up
on chocolate then I definitely can't
drink yeah
you only want oh you get like those I
love those reese's peanut butter cups I
mean that did I this is how untethered I
was to diet during these last 11 months
I would literally be on the road and I'd
go and grab go into a gas station and I
just grabbed [ __ ] what the four pack
of Reese's peanut butter cups yeah and
eat two and save two for later and then
eat those within a car ride afforable
yeah like that's so [ __ ] unhealthy
like there's no there's no part about
how I'm gonna seat back I just wanted
this they say that like if you're gonna
compare it to drinking now are those
reese's peanut butter cups are just so
much better realize because your body
has a harder time um digesting alcohol
and if you like if you drink your body
spends all its time breaking down the
alcohol first before it even gets to the
food so that food is just sitting in
your gut hold on so so your body knows
alcohol is poison right okay so it
always goes for the alcohol first so as
to process all this alcohol before it
can even start digesting the food all
right and so so when I go to jail and I
and I pull up to the bar and have a
couple cocktails before dinner yeah I've
just [ __ ] myself in a way I mean if
you have to it's not gonna be that much
of a problem yeah if you have 16 you're
not gonna digest that state for weeks
so having wine with your meal is a
horrible idea no it's not a horrible
idea it's just gonna take a little bit
longer one glass of wine ain't gonna
hurt you yeah especially I find if you
drink a glass of wine they eat something
you don't really have that thing where
you want to have another drink because
you're like full and it's just not gonna
it's not really gonna give you a buzz if
you have another glass of wine I got to
a place where I could not physically
drink beer yeah yeah it's so heavy I was
like I literally was like I get a drink
start drinking a beer and I'd start
feeling like I just felt like I wanted
to throw it up like it was just so
filling yes
so yeah that's what I mean alcohol makes
you fat in so many ways
I mean aight the day I drank this week I
went in and I gained like a pound and a
half and I didn't even eat that bad
absolute just shivers I guess I I was
doing really good then in one of the
roof four more days and I know I put on
at least five pounds when they're crazy
yeah
it took me like two months to get to
shed all that weight beforehand I got
cocky I was like dude I got this so I'm
what's the [ __ ] pills like what's the
what's the key how do you relax when
you're skinny um I don't know you got to
find an exercise that just wears you
though [ __ ] out yeah but if you're gonna
drink you've gotta [ __ ] beat on the
treadmill running 10 miles a day yeah
and then if you're doing that you don't
want to drink cause you don't want to
feel like [ __ ] when you're running 10
miles yeah I mean I think you get to a
certain age to wear like exercise just
like doesn't really combat calories like
it used to yeah so it's not like a even
math equation where like all right if I
burn 500 calories i can eat 500 calories
of garbage oh just doesn't work like
that do you want to hear something crazy
I burned 5,000 calories yesterday my
Fitbit says I did yeah because I because
i was up until [ __ ] one in the
morning like i got up at six in the
morning maybe girls breakfast i got up
at five forty-five yesterday and then i
stayed up till one right maybe that's
why i'm [ __ ] tired today and then i
looked at my fitbit it said it United
burned I'd burned 5,000 calories and I
was like what the [ __ ] that's impossible
rank there's like no it's not impossible
you just have been [ __ ] moving for a
22 hours 20 hours yeah
i love i love when i get notes on my
youtube channel from people about the
vlog yeah yeah this guy's note I like
like solid note second people that's you
yeah love the blog but you might want to
have you might want to only have music
sometimes I couldn't hear what the [ __ ]
Rogan was saying and and listen to song
at the same time well usually if I'm
playing the music it's because that
whatever is said was not like super
important right um yeah I want you to
take a look at the blog site tell me you
tugga I need some sort of [ __ ] I get
maybe that's why I already said skinnies
he just smokes weed all day yeah he's
not a big drinker I don't understand
those people I don't know i really like
i really like Bruce yeah I know it's not
the answer but I like it maybe you're
supposed to have liked but my wife will
have like three drinks tonight yeah and
be lit right you know but the thing is
about booze is it makes you make bad
decisions and those decisions are more
booze oh yeah so it's tough that's why I
say like have a glass or two and then
eat something then smoke some pot if
you're gonna smoke some pot think about
pot is it doesn't really make you want
to smoke more pot just makes you want to
go to bed once it wears off that's a
beautiful thing usually you think it
makes you want to bet good about once it
wears off yeah yeah that's a good idea
hey y'all just maybe I'll just turn into
a big meathead yeah like Benson I listen
to benson spot I listen to getting dug
with high all the time yeah heyhey if
they legalized in LA he should open a
store yeah absolutely he's got so many
fans a dead little people was come out
and just he just sat at the store all
day remember the 420 show we did no oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah I do act it out do
you remember how many [ __ ] bullets he
took that line he was really high I've
never seen anyone that hot he might have
taken a 100 bullets with people's pipes
because the big thing is everyone wants
to see up to get a picture right every
smoking out of their pipe yeah so then
when everyone when they have friends
over they can pull it up with her phone
and be like dude Doug Benson smoked out
of that pipe Beverly like in the green
room he was so hot you ask him a
question and then he just like smile for
a second and then answer yeah
like they they answer kinda the answer
in his head Khan and tickle them I was
blown away by how high he goes on stage
he was so high and it's such a
juxtaposition because Graham doesn't
smoke at all yeah and Graham's high
energy but everyone's stoned out of
there but Jesus's right
what a [ __ ] is a funny yeah it was a
[ __ ] black nose that don't know we
did it was a Sunday in San Francisco was
like a comedy festival cuz we did um
what we do we did his podcaster in the
day yes we've been we thank you show at
night and then we did his 420 stand-up
show after that me and you got beers see
that's I like being that untethered me
and you got beers in the afternoon like
we went walk in we went up and got
cheese steaks yeah we've got one beer
right before you cuz it was a beautiful
day and we just couldn't just couldn't
it was the last like beer garden before
Cobb's we weren't gonna go and then we
were just like you know what it's just
too nice we got a half an hour before
the show starts let's go have a beer do
this week periscope yeah that was like
at the infantile ages of periscoping
young um yeah
imagine this whole week will be sober
for me anyone as well if you're on a
roll Oh we'll see what happens tonight
if you [ __ ] up you got a ride home yeah
I know leanna leanna Leanne's coming
down party bus oh wow yeah so she was
like I see him see if Matt can uh I she
called you the full charge oh good see
if the full charge can bring you down so
you can ride back with me in the bus I
was like okay
this is a party bus on the way back two
hours ago Oh it'll be a sleepy throw up
bus on the way back cuz they're all
[ __ ] lightweight so they all like
screaming oh they get hammered on the
ride down then halfway through the show
their [ __ ] got to wake him up that's
one of the funniest things about comedy
shows is people don't know how to drink
oh and they it's one of those places
where people over do it girl the front
row to the left last night first show so
annoying oh my god burping up salad the
she was she was one of those people she
got [ __ ] hammered she has four kids
kind of hot yeah not hot enough to be
not annoying her guy was her got her guy
was her boyfriend I kind of liked him oh
we're getting some [ __ ] pace right
now
careful
wait for those listening we just have 15
seconds for 70 miles an hour no it's
also doesn't rush like Noah that was
like a big ball okay the ride home on
the on on irvine I what do you think's
worse because the ride home is full tilt
70 miles an hour but it still takes
forty five [ __ ] minutes it's scary on
the way home everyone's like [ __ ]
Tokyo drifting into each other yeah
trying to [ __ ] mad dog each other and
then nine times out of ten you'll hit
they'll do construction and then a
traffic will be down to one lane so that
was happening last night was rough [ __ ]
I didn't catch it last night but it
happens a lot do you remember that time
when they be shut down to five and you'd
have to take the 20 to the [ __ ] 122
the [ __ ] 70 to the beach drive to the
and then get old I was [ __ ] up here
first time I ever did their irvine
improv first of all this guy i was
showcasing for power which is your
management group now levity but do they
call themselves yeah and they were and
then i asked a guy that work there I go
how do I get to the room an improv egos
uh it starts to tell me that goes are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] if you can't find
it it's with a five and a four or five
meet and I was like okay thanks [ __ ]
maybe it's maybe it's backwards maybe
it's your [ __ ] idiot if you can't
describe it salam i'm heading down there
and all happens at thomas guy this is
like 2001 and i remember going into a
taco bell and I go hey where's the
where's the improv around here and the
Mexican guy was like I
it worked in my favor though cuz I
showed up late and I got to go on second
instead of first in seconds oh he's
better than first that's top um but I
just remember him saying that and then
on the way home the five was was you
know closed down and it was like I had
to just look at the Thomas guy to figure
out how to get home this is [ __ ] I
was like I'm I'll just keep driving home
eventually yeah I did the five I did the
improv in irvine pi the first time was
in
by 2001
point 2001-2002 thousand two thousand
one um and I remember thinking are you
sure the comedy club down here because
in New York all the comedy clubs were
like we're busy things were happening
yeah yeah I couldn't understand that you
would drive 45 minutes away to go to a
comedy client like I couldn't understand
that there would I was like blown away
that and like the enemies like packed I
was like wait where are these where am I
and they're like oh you get yogurt brea
this one braid with the old brave I
don't know right yeah that's the first
improv ever did I think besides
Hollywood I did the old brea I did the
old in old ontario improv I think was
there to entertain oh there they close
brea and then opened Ontario like we
still need a Brea oh so on Terra has
been the same Club the whole time yeah
you sure i'm pretty sure i don't know
they might add something else out there
but i don't remember it
irvine has only been in two places now
right yeah well three now if you count
that little move they did to see this
last year what's the third place well it
was a place that was closer to what's it
called a university of california irvine
i think it was way closer than that it
wasn't at the spectrum originally i
never played it oh yeah i never played
it either i heard this funny story that
taught class backed up a pickup truck to
like the entrance of the irvine improv
yeah back in the day and so when people
were exiting the club that he's like oh
welcome to the next comedy show folks
and even do comedy for them as they were
walking out oh he is so [ __ ] funny he
has one of my I heard that he would tell
the wait staff I can't remember how this
works but he would tell the wait staff
when he was going long just to come out
start vacuuming yeah I saw all that the
first time I ever worked brea was with
Todd and I was just blown away by like
just how what would you call it
just he kept exiting the reality of the
comedy show in other words like the like
he would have plants in the audience be
like mr. glass mr. glass you know which
was basically this kid chicken pizza and
[ __ ] the wait staff they were low
ever chicken pizza yeah they were
allowed to [ __ ] with Todd and he gave
him an open invitation he was making
fries oh yeah yeah yeah what else till
he's still see him in brea if you work
at brea not even working brain he's just
like a guy that hangs out did he stop
working the club right when i wrote
where I when I started working there
chicken pizza in Tijuana bullfights he's
not a guy's name no that was a band that
they one of the guys that I think now
irvine had do you want a bull fights I
think bill boli was telling me that at
one point
[ __ ] forgetting all the names but I
know Robert Hartman and when Stefan II
were both working at the improv as
waiters what that's what Bilbo he told
me he was a waiter too I'm sure erin was
there erin was a hostess yeah [ __ ]
the guy that ran Chris Hall bricks was a
bartender who's he got it ran HBO no
kidding like what are the [ __ ] odds
doesn't it seem like amigos aqui used to
run an improv to Danny yeah what does it
seem like if you just moved to LA in 91
you would have been successful yeah
seems that way those where biggest
comedy was dying then was it in the
early 90s so so the people that were in
it were in it passionate and right
everyone else like what's more
profitable but the people that loved it
stayed in it now that's weather today
what percentage of people you think love
it or just want to be famous in today's
society I think everyone that started in
the past eight years wants to be famous
as [ __ ] yes because everyone feels like
they can be famous cuz they kind of are
you many girls I follow on Instagram
there are nobody but I have like a
million followers yeah the [ __ ]
famous in a way
it is kind of crazy that someone could
become famous do you remember a girl
named tila tequila yes she got famous
off myspace I remember her for doing
nothing you wouldn't even that cute she
was just on myspace and popular what's
she doing now I don't know golfing
bullying her I seen her in a porno Oh
show at seven shy was thus Avondale Road
what the Todd glass it and do it for my
car my closet no herb you know I love
Todd glass he said to me he said um what
time he goes it be said in front of
LeAnn so likely an the anahat doesn't
know Todd very well so she doesn't get
his entire personality right um so he
goes yeah won't you do my podcast and I
said yeah definitely and he's like I'm
and I really would want to do it we just
hasn't been able to work out yet and
he's like no but I wanted to be like
special I was like yeah I agree he's
like no I want it to be like real
special like you come over and maybe
like spend the night and like we do in
the morning over breakfast and I was
like yeah but you know when Todd says
that it's a good idea right because you
can imagine that you guys hang out all
night and [ __ ] get weird and everyone
everyone's over there and everyone
passes out and then he wakes up he does
something fun the morning right I think
that sounds awesome they leave something
I'd like what you to spend the night at
a dudes house and I was like I was it
was Todd she goes we mean boats Todd
you're like honey it's cool he has a
boyfriend yeah I'm not gonna hook up
with him she said Burt you're 42 I was
42 it's on your foot you have kids come
home but it's like Todd's personalities
so like I know here you spend the night
and will wake up early and maybe we'll
make like donuts or something right and
it's like it does sound funny [ __ ] yeah
you make a great parent
yeah for sure cuz he's so silly I was so
[ __ ] get in the zone with the kid
real easy he should like he should adopt
like a troubled kid who doesn't been
able to [ __ ] breathe you know like
hadn't had the space to breathe funny
thing is if you tell him you'd probably
do it yeah where the [ __ ] was this that
I drove to
we are 41 minutes away really yep that's
what traffic right with traffic yeah
we're halfway there right now I think
yeah dude this is how much LA County
doesn't give a [ __ ] about us it's only
three lanes what are they doing with all
this [ __ ] center area well they're
gonna make us new lanes but me and
you'll be [ __ ] in the old folks home
once I upset you like are you skip said
I was thinking about today is that well
[ __ ] man i'm never gonna get to
experience like like I forget what the
thing was but I was like underneath
experience that the Metro is gonna be
amazing when we're dying oh I bet like
they're they're working on it and it's
gonna go every which way now how great
would that well there i'm sure there was
kinda covered wagon bumping his ass to
[ __ ] in san francisco going one day this
will all be paved and we'll be dead one
day I'll have a car and we'll go even
slower and slower I just feel like why
is everything going so slow what in
there a guy at the front is there a guy
at the front trying to change lanes
right now um it's weird it's like a
chain reaction so if something slows
down three hours ago we're still dealing
with it that wouldn't mind doing that
for a TV show like getting a helicopter
of fine traffic right I guess they do
that I guess they do that in the morning
to news the news the reason there's
traffic is there's an accident let me
should have fun of you fixed that up are
you pitching us the news right now good
and then we'll have a guy that does the
weather like you're gonna know what it's
gonna be like oh I ever wonder if it's
gonna rain like we should know that [ __ ]
and if people are doing crimes out there
we should report it because you know
people want to know this stuff
but like what the [ __ ] why is everyone
driving so slow cuz there's a second
where it just opens up number one speeds
you know what I mean yeah what a number
one speed to that speeding place we
should all stop all at once and then
I'll hit the gas at the same time and
just start cruising do you think it's
just one [ __ ] just causing this just
[ __ ] laughing and slowing down these
are look at all those [ __ ] behind me
for a second man I thought that someone
had built a chair on the back of their
car for someone to sit I was like why
would they put him there not be a [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] out of it today I get really
other have you ever seen a cop do this
thing where they swerve back and forth
and stop the traffic yes so that happens
and then like I say it's like there's so
many cars it becomes a chain reaction I
had a knob do it I had a cop do it right
it was on the was it the four or five I
think was a 405 I was in my buddy Eddie
and I had him do it right behind us like
literally right behind us right and we
were in front of him and Eddie's like
oak get behind him he's like I was like
why is that cuz then you can see what's
gonna happen there they're slowing down
traffic for a high-speed car chase right
I was like oh yeah she slowed down and
got in the traffic yeah yeah and then I
realized oh no we're never gonna see it
all right yes see they got no carpool
lane like orange county they care about
their peoples hey don't give a [ __ ] what
watch rounds once we hit the county line
there's get was that with me that's what
yeah yeah it's gonna be five lanes and
six if you count the carpool you got to
carpool lanes a super go find the county
loadable or so does these taxes were
paying in LA
they might as well just be constructing
a big middle finger for our faces to
look at I can't believe that Matt you're
a hundred percent accurate the second we
crossed the county line if [ __ ] turns
from red orange el he hates it's [ __ ]
citizens oh my god I wonder if it's like
that in brea that's just like that
everyone and the traffic slows down
coming the other direction right at that
point oh yeah cuz there's no lanes three
lanes dude that's [ __ ] outrageous do
you think that that has anything to do
with the burden that I'm certain that is
accrued by so many undocumented workers
in LA I don't know by like clearly like
I would say what would you say like I'm
in this probably about this is just a
guess I'll find out the fact in the side
the number in a second what percentage
of the people that live in LA are
documented citizens documented I would
say somewhere between seventy and eighty
percent so I guess I'll say 75 I was
gonna say seventy-five percent to its
good question let me help me out Cirie
stuff because you can't really do a
consensus Cirie oh yeah I guess you
can't what's [ __ ] I say look dumb garden
they've got an estimate Cirie how many
people live in LA are undocumented much
Syria races
let me think okay I saw this on the web
how many people live in LA are
documented 11 million people are
undocumented in LA that's a lot of
goddamn people okay let's find out how
many people Siri how many people live in
LA County let me check that okay I saw
this on the web from how many people
live in LA County 48 million live in LA
no wait that can't be right wait there
are 48 thousand people living on the
streets that's a lot of goddamn people
whoa that really is
the census has a population of nine
million what did I say 11 million yeah
so that that mean that fifty percent of
the people in the city are undocumented
I don't know you had nine million at 11
million well if there's 11 million
undocumented people in la then and
there's nine million documented Jesus
lives do the census take holy more
undocumented so did you looking at like
55 to 60 percent are undocumented yeah
demographics let's get demographics but
then what is undocumented me because
that could that could just be people not
filling out the census
total populations I'll total population
is the correct question is illegal
immigrant yab I'm trying to be
politically correct but I don't think
they recognize that is let's see
okay here we go here we go
an estimate an estimate by the Public
Policy Institute of California 2008 said
los angeles county is home to more than
one-third of all of California's legal
immigrants I had at all because I think
it made it more clear I one-third of
California's legal immigrants who make
up more than ten percent of the
population okay so ten percent of the
population is illegal immigrants illegal
illegal immigrants so there's roughly
like nine hundred thousand a million
illegal immigrants then where did they
come up with out of 11 million number is
probably the country and I don't know
let's break this down fifty two percent
of la is white really try to guess what
percent you're never gonna guess this
what what percentage of la is black 11-8
Wow I know make sense you don't see a
lot of black people Native American oh
um point eight percent point five good
job asian ah 2213 okay uh Pacific
Islanders irrelevant and not irrelevant
but it's point three yeah it's yeah
somewhat
fine okay ready for this one this that
yeah how what percentage of the people
in Los Angeles Angeles are some other
rates some other race yeah because five
percent 21-percent this is some other
race they just [ __ ] there's a lot
more going on in LA then what percentage
is two or more races Jesus Christ three
hispanic or latino wow I guess it's not
shocking consider the name of our cities
Los Angeles what is it forty-seven
percent does that really check out 52
plus 47 yeah that doesn't [ __ ] check
out like the blacks yeah how does that
make sense it doesn't it doesn't have to
152 percent eight percent so that's
sixty percent thirteen percent at
seventy-three percent twenty one percent
that's oh no no I did I might have done
this wrong because 52 plus 47 is 99
right
oh no I'm sorry I did this wrong no wait
I hope you do this wrong where's
Armenian that's in the other some other
race other maybe I did this wrong
understand
total population
[ __ ] it um yeah that doesn't the average
household income in Los Angeles
thirty-five thousand dollar Oh average
household per capita income I think it's
only like 50,000 median household income
is 56,000 any two people man median
family income is 62,000 that's crazy
yeah man that's rough
that's that average son I could I could
watch a TV show that just broke down
statistics of a city yeah right I'm so
hungry for something that just gives me
fax these days I know because everyone's
got their opinion on the facts yeah yeah
it's like I could go to a website and
you see this thing they're like you read
something our website and it's like uh
dr. talk to our thought feminists a
horseshit argument a microaggression
[ __ ] social justice warrior and
you're like yeah I kind of grew with
that and then you realize you're reading
a red state documents and you're like oh
[ __ ] I don't want can't agree with you
we also wonder you're gonna say that
[ __ ] everyone also pulls the facts that
they want because there's so many
sources of truth now quote unquote truth
know that like if you're running for
president you go well this is true this
is a statistic and no one goes where you
getting that from everyone just goes
yeah alright cuz no ones even suede
anymore anyways everybody knows exactly
what they want to thank ya and they
wanted his root for a team it's like
sports politics like sports now yeah no
one's kind of open mind I'm looking on
the internet wanting to hear both sides
of the story I want a non biased
viewpoint yeah so I can form my
viewpoint because I really am on the
fence I think I could either go either
way meet the gun control clearly there's
a problem with [ __ ] firearms gets all
emotional though we get all emotional
but at the same time I understand
wanting to have a gun right I get that
like like so and I want a gun I just
don't take the [ __ ] test I don't
wanna take the test cuz it's gonna take
too long I just want it now yeah like
I'm a kind of guy that would be like
like totally realize that gun laws need
to be established but I'm not guy that
would be like do I really need a [ __ ]
waiting period I want it now
haha I said something about abortion
last night but like i'm gonna post types
of threats on everything I when I want
is an unbiased opinion so I can for my
opinion yeah like a no-bullshit website
because these are the facts like a
malcolm gladwell that's why Malcolm
Gladwell appeals so many people it's cuz
his [ __ ] stats are exactly that stats
and it's like air this percentage
movement of people are in jail or black
guys were in jail of the black
population that's why when abortion
showed up in 70s fine went down like a
local girl a [ __ ] books yeah outliers
all I know tipping point or something
maybe breaking windows one of the one of
those let's see when this traffic stops
well close we the county line
not close enough uh in very shortly
we're gonna press a river
we're gonna pass that in and out on the
left and then we're hooked up I could go
for [ __ ] in and out it's funny we did
this new year show together in irvine
this past year and i was looking at
Twitter and I saw you this is on new
year's day you were like first meal of
the year it was a picture in and out and
I was like I hated the same I get it now
yeah oh yeah we did do we do that show
together same lineup Jen me and you oh
[ __ ] that was a year ago I like that
memories on facebook where they tell you
hey Stefan years ago you're making fun
of this um no I think I had I to good
use here and I think about you on stage
gone we are gonna [ __ ] 2015 in the ass I
had a good year this year too yeah so
say that more often mian Hartman looked
at each other like [ __ ] we both said to
each other a lot yeah a good yard worked
a lot right a good year
quite bad year for health I wonder what
I weighed back then
probably like to 35 to 35 you telling me
you getting 20 pounds this year oh yeah
easily well I can probably tell you
exactly what I wait then
to be our Facebook didn't tell you down
it won't be cool they pulled your stats
and they're like like like I'm not
totally at first to the Internet knowing
everything about me and tracking all my
[ __ ] like if they were like someone's
like you know they're gonna [ __ ]
check with you google and then they'll
suddenly ads on that [ __ ] well yeah
thank you though thank you yeah that's
quick in the space up why all my hats
for depression isn't [ __ ] ahead oh I
remember once i'm a manager be like
never say your age on stage but now it's
just like everyone knows everything
about you [ __ ] there's nothing you
never say you're a jones yeah yeah 27 to
that's how [ __ ] worried they were
feeling Majesty you're 24 the funny
thing is try to find the threshold
number they get to laugh right exactly
not like like feel like I'm 32 and
everyone believes it yeah I'm 29 and
like find the number where no one
believes it ready I'm 58 and
let's see
like people only tell you you look good
if you tell if you're honest about your
age all right I think
oh there's gonna be girls with checkered
flags here in a second
my wheels are starting to itch
oh well this is depressing
what are you looking up after yahoo a
mobile
Oh you look always way too
this can't be right this must be march
april may june august/september october
november december so this must be by two
years ago so wasn't this June I know
that I was 231 and you're getting close
to that again right right now no I'm 243
well I'm in ten pounds away from it yeah
what you 30 loan was my that way
yep we just pass the county line orange
county orange county line do you see
that yeah that sign that said orange
county line now we're [ __ ] flying you
notice no homeless or blacks autos this
is [ __ ] ridiculous man thank you for
my carpool lane Orange County
my old lover she don't treat me so right
dude it's la that's for balked fun
it's almost like that that Kurt Russell
movie live and die in LA yeah it's just
like LA so pumped getting out of it so
hard yeah can you imagine if there was a
disaster oh won't even bother yeah just
hunker down and tape up your windows
yeah [ __ ] go get a hot dog and pigs
yeah I always have a full tank of gas
just in case something like that
happened is I who am I [ __ ] kidding
this is like just Christmas shopping
what we're dealing with today how the
[ __ ] would you get out of LA you can't
your best bet are the metros actually
because most people don't even know how
to use them
that's when you need a motorcycle did
you mention be honest you always need a
motorcycle I'm thinking about buying one
just to have ya floating around the
house
just to take it like did you take them
around the neighborhood it's fine yeah I
don't think you should ever ride him on
the highways oh I can't imagine anyone
to tell us I've done it before in like
different states and it's [ __ ] scary
this is not a good idea what this little
[ __ ] turn in a jersey wall or in the
moon yeah what is that more that's nuts
orange county is a cruel lover she's
inviting going going I think the fastest
I've ever gone on of butter I probably
on pretty fast but steadily the fastest
is probably 70 miles an hour yeah and
it's scary as [ __ ] I've only ever gone
like on a residential street when I was
a kid it was allows only on like 20 30
oh I've gone I've taken a motorcycle I
think took like probably like 80 before
versus maybe 70 but it is scary man
you're very vulnerable absolutely like
you realized very quickly oh [ __ ] man
this isn't a joke like jr. Dean Del Rey
got sideswiped what oh yeah I guess
that's why I'm going like 70 80 he's
fine what happened he was doing that
thing in the movies were like like in
that Chicago video will like he's just
sliding down the goddamn Road are you
sure you could easily got run over
Susie Dunn rise for sales oh he told me
he goes I got a car but then I think
another motorcycle
it's hard once you get that in your
blood yeah exactly Alonzo Bodden has
been riding motorcycles it's a whole
[ __ ] life yeah
he's in the military though it's
different haha Junior did you hear him
talking about his addiction to coke no
wow man I wish I knew what he talked
about this on whatsapp Rogan you do
broken Robin and he talked corolla
before I know
he talked he he talked about being
addicted to coke
like just what he went through and man I
wish I remembered more stuff because I
was a really good conversation should
check it out it whatever but like I knew
he had addiction problems are you sober
but I didn't realize how bad he was
seems like like there's definitely
sucking dudes dicks Oh kidding no I'm
line I like it's not a guy what sucking
my dick Alonzo Bodden
think of comics you can't imagine
sucking your dick everybody no name
because they've like one we were like
well that guy definitely would never do
it would never do it like no like or
just it would be so uncomfortable like
it's all about comfortable but like you
go first okay I can't imagine Joey Diaz
sucking my tail lap no i got a badge
atari or Duncan ok but not Joey Diaz now
you're gonna get it oh it's just gonna
get a beaten dog stop moving gonna bite
you [ __ ] fog man trying to do your favor
here oh by the way Joey would not find
that funny now so sorry Joe
that's okay
Oh to [ __ ] me chose it's so much easier
to cells will you drink for them yeah
detection unless you ever do it on the
first one no it cuz you have a World War
waiting for you right you see they
declare me a drink you're like oh can we
get the club and get a drink
then when you're not drinking you like
again we did go to the club and get a
water to put salads there I don't have
that at home
Oh burping up whatever [ __ ] salad I
have so much green [ __ ] my body yeah
it's funny cuz that she's good for year
but he's just like doesn't even know
what to do with it anywhere like just
get it out my body's little so we were
just [ __ ] all this out right let's
make I mean they don't even know if it's
getting the nutrients from it or just
[ __ ] it out every should i take this
green it's good I'd like to put I wish
they were there was like a pill you
could swallow it was almost gonna flare
in your intestines so it would like
right when that you swallow that pill
that would block everything in front of
it and behind it yeah and create like a
like a like an inch of solid like breath
like just like a our pink for us and
pink so that everything you ate you can
find out if there was stuff in front of
that like you oh that's from yesterday's
mail my marker went through all right
that would be interesting but I think
certain things stay in longer than
others really yeah like they say me
takes a long time to digest it stays in
your stomach much longer than salad you
ate so you got baby some red meat in
your stomach from like a month ago no
Dudley that won't go [ __ ] lettuce I
don't know if it's a month
you know vegetarians tell you never
comes out talk Siri Siri how long does
red meat stay in your stomach
my sources isn't a star
heartbeats pain in her stomach
does red meat rod near colon uh-huh I
don't need a lot of red meat come on
oh here's another thing this is telling
what we're just talking about
it's a dot org so it and it's all
hunting gorg it's all [ __ ] Safari
it's a hunting org so they gonna tell
you something different than the person
most vegetarian propaganda yes and it's
an inversion of the truth right most
vegetarian propaganda is not just false
it's an inversion of the truth okay here
we go I like crush fruit or mouth where
it analyzes breaks down some of the
starches in the stomach epson breaks
down the protein and strong I can't read
we can't forget arena make a car surgery
but so it basically this is a propaganda
website I can't even get a [ __ ]
honest answer on like how long sudden
meets a relic see their [ __ ]
vegetarians or hunters telling me one
thing try to make up a website like
anatomy commerce biology calm see if I
can go back look like they had wanted
hitters
oh did you know that the
Siri how long does red meat stay in your
stomach
let me check on that shuttle engine back
the web from how long does red meat
state
Just Answer com
well they don't have an answer
[ __ ] ridiculous
it's all traffic stopped up there are we
just in a bad way no I think it's all
going I think we're in a bad lame why is
the [ __ ] car pool Lane slow
makes no [ __ ] sense
is there some guy broken down on the
[ __ ] carpool lane cuz I lose my [ __ ] we
got a show to do what time oh it says
would be there 644 that's if there's no
traffic we got 12 miles ago oh
all night all night party she's coming
over Darris it there lay in bed and go
what exactly is my talent and people are
paying me for uh yeah I say that a lot I
can go like
theoretically could like a bear could do
my job like if you could teach a bear to
ice skate it would definitely be more
entertaining than watching me doing
stand-up sometimes and you can teach
bears to ice skate and do flips that
stand up in general though it's just
some dude talking for an hour hour and a
half shell little wiser than even paying
for the studio discerning Weiss you'd
pay one guy more money than another guy
yet like wiley David Spade make more
money than then you wanna smoke in
raindell ray you know I'm gonna see his
grill that's why you oh that's that
grill that I recognized there was a
shame it is him oh we're merging with
these [ __ ]
that would have been it could help their
Serie I don't know how long red meat
stays in your stomach but getting the
right hand lane yeah see that's where
I'm cool with the internet taking over
everything right and having a puter
computer chip in my ear and then just
going no yeah Robert I noticed you're in
the right hand lane there will be
traffic as you merge with the left hand
lane get in the far right you're pumping
too hard right now you won't last two
and a half minutes i wish i had like i
wish i had like a barometer in my head
where it was like some little voice it
would be like hey you've talked about
this one subject too long onstage change
subjects you're making people feel
uncomfortable I definitely made people
feel comfortable last night talking
about things i find shameful like what
[ __ ] subject like why would I bring
that up I think a woman was losing her
[ __ ] right yeah she was like kid Palace
dead it was like that person I can't
understand because I go stuffing on us
about anything yeah and I can't stand
that I don't mind it like that one that
one lady we were I said something about
let's find out how let's find out no no
whatever I want him talking about it but
like the thing about the that's kinda
gross she's never got [ __ ] on her
fingers like no show your child's I was
like never had a person's and everyone
started getting around or be like wait
what are you talking about you never I
don't show your finger check never I was
like no she clearly has just not
comfortable sharing that with all right
but then it's people like that I don't
mind them lying and being silent did
that one girl the far left was just
annoying yeah it was like I was like oh
that's gross you're disgusting I'm like
stop it you're what's bad for this
country she can't [ __ ] saying
opinions that aren't really your
opinions because you've gotten [ __ ] on
your finger to write just trying to
preserve your CI you're simply saying
what you think everyone's gonna say as
opposed to saying what you think ooh
like Oh what I was talking about she
gave birth she had four kids and I
mentioned that my wife [ __ ] during
childbirth and she was like oh gross I
didn't do that I was like yeah you did
they just didn't tell you like don't
middle like bring it up no one said it I
just I'm acadian I'm telling the story
right whoo that's gross you're gross
your wife's gross you're like
I am I like talking about a second car
though we have been looking at cars for
about a year and cannot find a [ __ ]
car how come everything's too expensive
that I want uh-huh and then what I what
we can afford I just don't want to drive
round it right well [ __ ] hold out one
day was just be staring you right in the
face yeah the drive right past it that's
like I like like we could afford a Jeep
but I was like I'm 43 I can't be driving
around the Jeep like and like a cheap
cheap chair like a jeep and lands like
went to cool car I was like yeah but I'm
not a personal trainer like yeah I'm me
what am i driving cheap down to the
[ __ ] improv gonna stick I'll lose my
goddamn I know and then halfway through
i'll go and make more money than
deserved a ride to drive a stick down to
the thing because my wife thinks it's a
cool car
I want like a big body luxury sedan yeah
I like that [ __ ] i had a Chrysler 300
did I tell you that I love you wish to
see oh it broke my heart when I saw it
wrecked it's just like destroyed segura
used to have an Impala which I loved and
he hated but i loved it I was like this
is a relaxing car yeah anytime you feel
like you're driving a couch showing up
on water yeah that's that feeling that
town car like old school
tough guy car
look at this [ __ ]
that was almost me last night as I was
driving home my was [ __ ] I was at
like four thousand rpms on the highway I
was like that's not and I can hear it I
was like what the [ __ ] so I like slow
down thinking it just wasn't changing
gears yeah and then finally I pulled
over to the side of the road I was like
[ __ ] my car's overheating yeah and I had
it in third gear oh [ __ ] I had it in
like Santa fifth and no instead of like
dr d hey I got you you snow [ __ ] gear
on yeah 3 love
we'll be there 10 minutes
I might as well podcast ourselves into
the green room as well
agente Gover I'm sure the levels have
been atrocious on this
if you guys don't like the levels just
all you if you're already here you're
like what [ __ ] already buried it through
it yeah like remix it yeah and then put
it out for us oh it's fine it's funny
Doug Benson you know what song that is
yes prevention the nursery yeah i def
putting my blog today y'all play it for
you
this but they're not party this is what
laminates
the pi lam should be here any second
what was the name of the black guy l ll
know uh dl no staying in his name the
guy the Revenge of the Nerds come un un
un you I'm glad you know you guys
finally got back at them it's so funny
they're in the office and he's like I
can't I can't we can't have you guys
never eternity and then one of them's
like the main guys like well it says
right here you have to like at least
give us a trial period he's like all
right un hey guys
your joints hey guys dad papa ba ba ba
bum gee that was a good move you move
sure can party by the way they go
through and sexually assault the pi lam
by lambs so much sexual misconduct he
rapes that girl he rapes the girl and
they also put cameras in the sorority
house yeah they put cameras in the
sorority house and then watch them get
naked all day total sexual [ __ ]
heinous conduct he rapes the girl so
well she falls in love with him yep that
is telling you if you can trick a girl
in the [ __ ] you she may fall in love
even before I knew the laws I watched
that I got you dude uh I remember
thinking I remember thinking that's my
move this is okay yeah just real quick
grab someone's helmet and walk hand and
[ __ ] his girlfriend with a helmet on
that's crazy that that is straight-up
rape straight up ray he's the hero yo
do you think anyone said that in the
writers room they're like hey man seems
like Luis rape sure right and they're
like no that happens I had a friend that
happened to ya and he didn't get
arrested you ever seen those porns where
it's like rushing guys and they
blindfold a girlfriend there [ __ ] him
and then also their brother their friend
comes in me either then but I know I'm
aware that that can easily go down oh
yeah one goes down into Ukraine a lot oh
yeah yeah she wear a blindfold during
this one yeah who wears up and then and
then it always backfires on the guy
because she ends up liking it right
you've added virtual and it's up like I
think it's a little stage I'm glad you
rang me up I'm upset that you raped me
but I did like it so I guess you're off
the hook yeah
I said to someone the other day I was
talking to someone and I said I'm pretty
certain any sexual story where it was
two guys on one girl is pretty much
great think so like any time it's more
than like two guys it's definitely right
yeah yeah okay like definitely you
should definitely if you if at one point
one of your buddies says eighty-one'st
[ __ ] this guy this girl with me and my
friend right you should definitely go
hey man you need to check yourself right
now I think what's going down is
unlawful right because I've been a lot
of whether it is or not it's gonna go
down as unlawful yeah because even if
she says she wants to that she doesn't
want to yeah it's crazy that the laws
set up that as a guy you have to be two
steps ahead of what the girl wants right
shift of electroactive feelings yeah cuz
if I mean kids I mean I've been in a
situation where a girl was about was was
like totally willing to [ __ ] a couple of
guys ah totally willing and I was one
that pointed out but I pointed out this
before any of the there's a new era of
pc yeah this is back in the day when
that [ __ ] didn't go down and I was
looked at it's like a dick for being
like guys it feels a little rapey yeah
and someone's like why would you even
say that [ __ ] worse soon as that word
comes up she's like yeah as soon as that
work came up her attitude change exactly
yeah what the [ __ ] is going on and I was
like I'm just saying what I feel like I
like Delta seems uncomfortable yeah
but uh but like yeah I don't think
there's any scenario really wear it
where and I've never heard of a girl a
legit girl being into two guys at once
um I've heard somebody talk about it and
they were cool with it a girl yeah she
brought it up for no reason sign like
she was the story Jesus like yeah when I
was in high school these two guys came
over and I was like you know what I'm
gonna hook these guys up and she talked
about it in a proud way and she already
Greenwich very hot I'll tell you it is
after the podcast I know work yeah she
even said in the podcast I don't know
why I still feel like saying her name
yeah
cuz she's a hero and I don't want to
call her out yeah that yeah no no no
that's crazy two girls when one guy is
totally [ __ ] goes in her parents
house they're really can you imagine to
file your parents living room I'm Dino
hood is known but get to be a problem
what if I should eat again if I should
not super hungry though
me
maybe I'll started Christmas tree lot in
my front yard
for one just to meet a little extra cash
Olga yeah honey I decided I'm not going
on the road anymore I'm now Christmas
tree salesman like every December I just
decided to stop doing Santa but just
felt christmas trees that'd be fun
actually I should they be more than one
comic that would like rather work at
your store then go on the road that
month it would nice it around a [ __ ] off
will you sets at night yeah like I mean
I bet you can I bet how much do
Christmas trees are expensive [ __ ] like
300 bucks right considering they're
afraid you're not for us yeah and
they're very expensive to they grow out
of the ground yeah they are pretty
expensive considering that there's one
right there yeah there's a bunch over 70
oh no one even planted it oh yeah if you
like you figure your overheads what this
is gonna be expensive is by all the
treat yeah well you guys are awesome are
you gotta drop a least 20 grand to get
by trees you want prime location but
it's at your house then you come in and
people are like
like they feel like they had an intimate
experience right especially I mean
you're in a good position you can
advertise what your twitter feed I can't
advertise on your podcast you can
advertise maybe on the Travel Channel
and all your shows come but here's my
address come by my house like thing
about st. David Spade he's kind of a big
front yard re absolutely part lives in a
mansion right corner if he lives in a
mansion you think it'll American you
lose an imagined aye sir
serie where's David Spade live ok I
found this
tell me wear gloves masculine imagine
Siri does David Spade live in a mansion
okay okay i saw this on the way yes he
does David Spade selasis 10.3 million
dollar man Malibu mansion dude pennpoint
this is heart stops us oh yeah
oh yeah he loves the mansion all right
on the beach what the fog
he listened in 2007 didn't sell until
2013 yeah cuz remember 2008 went down oh
yeah was really looking for a house
right down it's on the PCH I only made a
925 thousand dollars off the mansion
poor guy man he had a great [ __ ]
place the Malibu mansion and it was on
the beach on the PCH think about how
long his career's been he's been making
millions for longer than when I was in
height like when I was in college what
is this I can't make a left turn right
no no you don't know I need to go what's
the next why they're okay right yeah I
think you're right yes you pulled out of
work you know what yeah
we think it's net worth is oh I'm not
good at this Syrian what's david spade's
net worth okay holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] what
are we looking at let me guess 130
million dollars no that's too hot 40
million dollars it'd be nice to have
that's nice cushion so that's like a
it's like I may or may not work this
decade 40 million dollars what has he
done with 40 million dollars it's the
fact that he's been working for 20 years
and just doing everything yeah and it's
leashed and wives even do a stand-up hey
does he does a lot of stand-up you must
love it
maybe a neat guy to know my friend Bobby
Miyamoto opens form all the time Oh
seriously yeah today is this already
unlocked this isn't us is it near this
yeah that's us does it just open all
about it oh I missed the [ __ ] we have
to go in the other way don't know yeah
you missed it it's the other one this is
the exit
I don't see the entrance over here but I
think we need to go further down the
road no no no you see an entrance right
there cuz I don't we're back there
there's gotta be next if this is the
exit oh that hit though I don't know if
that's it I think so is there another
one
where's the PF changs right
let's try this one over here I think it
might be right here okay by the steak
place I've all turn around there's the
Edward inside out over there early be
right over here yeah I think you're
right it might be the next one you
getting all this podcast listeners it
was exciting you guys I hope you guys
were enthralled you know when Congress
go to gigs they can't always find it
even though they've been working there
for 15 years um yeah let make a short
list of celebrities you'd like to just
start folding into your life me yeah i
think i'd like to hang out with Luke
Perry I think I'd like to hang out with
he's in your swing zone yeah yeah he
lives right around me does he yeah his
kid used to go to our school he said
kids are older isn't that crazy that
like [ __ ]
Dillon has high school kids oh yeah
and medium bag saw him at a comic book
convention in louisville kentucky month
on what are they doing Kurtz yeah
I wouldn't mind starting to hang out I
don't think I could hang out with
Sandler I want to hang out with Michael
Rapaport I really love his podcast I
think he's mine he's got a podcast yeah
this is it right here yeah good job hey
how come you doctor you know we were
coming in he knows when late good time
man oh yeah we are late where can I
apply I pulled in right to pull and just
back up right there dananana well I
can't say that this was the greatest
podcast we've ever done definitely a
podcast
post-roll what's that mean it means
after your podcast you okay go ahead ok
so again if you want to listen to it
audible has it with more than a hundred
and eighty thousand audiobooks and
spoken word products you'll find what
you're looking for so get a free
audiobook and a 30-day trial today by
signing up at www blue audible
podcast.com slash broadcast again that's
WWE audible podcast.com slash Bert cast
and check out my check out my blog on my
YouTube page let's go to Bert Bert Bert
calm and you can find all my [ __ ] there
but go to burp Roberta comp and go
shopping to our amazon banner on /
casscom all right have a great great
great rest of your weekend all right you
know this I don't need to say it I'll
say it anyway I love you